hi I'm Evan Carmichael welcome to
another edition of ask Evan in today's
video I'm going to answer question from
one of my readers on youtube so x1 our
YouTube video watchers who is a 16 year
old boy from Ireland who was seeking to
starting his own business and wanted my
help and coming up with some ideas for
how we could launch his company he's
thinking that something potentially in
the schools or the local stores and he
also lives next to a successful Lori
delivery service and he's wondering if
he can proposing the ideas to help him
grow his business as well so great
questions whenever I'm talking to new
entrepreneurs and helping them figure
out what businesses start I always
encourage you to think about something
they're really passionate about excited
about something that gets you motivated
and excited and it's something where you
think you can add a lot of value and
have an impact when you're working with
your customers so running the business
isn't just about making money although
we want to make money but it's about
adding value and really trying to be
significant to your customers and if
you're adding a ton of value and you're
being significant and you're having an
impact on their lives then the money is
going to follow they're going to keep
you around so that's the first thing so
figure out what it is that you're really
good at where you think you can add
value and help your customers the next
thing you've talked about selling into
your schools or selling to businesses
and it's pointing to figure out if you
want to be a business and consumer type
of model where you're selling to your
students and classmates or if you want
to be a business business have model and
sell to local entrepreneurs who might be
able to value for your services when
you're starting up I think it's a lot
easier to start a business the business
type of service and business-to-consumer
for a couple reasons one if you are
having a meaningful impact on somebody's
business they're going to want to keep
you around and they're making money from
it so they're going to want to keep
making sure you deliver in that product
or service because they're benefiting
from it where consumers often the price
tag is a lot lower so a business who is
making money from you is going to be
able to you know afford your services
where consumers if you sell your
students they may not have a lot of
money could be hard to build up business
and
you have a ton of students who are
buying from you and consumers sounds can
be fickle so they might like you today
and not like you tomorrow and then
you've got to start all over again from
scratch so it's not that you can't set a
consumer-facing business it's just a lot
more difficult so again tap into what
you think you can add a lot of value to
and try to build your business around
that the third part you're asking about
the successful lower delivery service
guide who's next to you and what you
might be able to offer him and there's a
great opportunity for a lot of young
entrepreneurs who might be more tech
savvy and online savvy to partner up
with establish entrepreneurs who might
need help on those online marketing
tactics so I know you're one of my
youtube video Watchers so maybe there's
a way you can use YouTube to help him go
his business maybe you can film intros
of him or film and what he does in his
business or marketing campaign and put
that on youtube so he can help promote
his business there be kept with this
website there's some other online
marketing with Twitter or Facebook a lot
of the established entrepreneurs they
know about YouTube they know about
Twitter and Facebook but they don't
really know what to do about it so as
young entrepreneur it could be an
opportunity to come in and show them how
it works also you get some valuable you
know education as you work through that
process hopefully it can work out for
that one client and you can go find
other clients start working worth a few
/ successfully proved it with the first
one so hopefully that helps if you have
other questions please leave a comment
below I'd also love to hear everybody
else's thoughts and feedback if you want
to leave a comment and please give the
video a thumbs up if you liked it and
will stay tuned to the next episode
you